okay man let's talk about the year that
you just had like if you if anyone's
gonna have a life-changing
transformative year it was like 2018 for
you man you must be still flying high
yeah it was it's definitely a life
through a bunch of fantastic changes at
me and personally and professionally
it's been it was an incredible year yeah
definitely I called my my year of growth
and and learning yeah yeah can we talk
about the engagement in a beautiful
place to the most beautiful person in
the world for you right oh yeah how did
it happen what'd you do man
may we so I uh I really I talked to her
mom and dad we went to her mom and dad's
house on Thanksgiving and so I went
there and she runs every day for miles
so I knew I was like I know I got an
hour where she's not gonna be around it
so I asked her mom she was gone and her
mom and dad and I got back to their
place and I asked him and they said yes
and her mom right away was like where do
you want to do it that's like I don't
know you know like she kind of I kind of
like hinted you know guys guys right
yeah hey so if you ever did think about
ever being proposed to if it would ever
happen how would you like it she's like
I think you'll know and I was like so
gave me a lot of room to work with but
then a lot of room to really mess this
up right and so but we just had we had
this family vacation with her her mom
and dad and I in Tulum Mexico so we're
like what better place yeah Tulum Mexico
it's our first time being there it's our
first family vacation all four of us so
I rented this top deck of this private
or this boutique resort that we were
staying at and her I couldn't have done
it without her mom like her mom helped
me do everything and she's an only child
and her mom a really close so I really
wanted her mom to be a part of it as
much as possible so she would have that
but also because I knew between her and
I we're gonna nail everything Carly yeah
we love and it's so we're emailing back
and forth him and with you know with
their guys in Tulum and figuring all the
stuff out and I said I want this to be
huge I wanted to be a moment I won't be
like a movie moment for her and so we
got it all done and it was a little
scary because we were setting all this
stuff up and I mean I brought off white
flowers and these florists stuff and
this he's white
I guess you like curtain type things at
a private dinner and all the stuff of a
heart of photographer and a mariachi
band another one right and it's so well
I did we got there on the 18th and 19th
was what I knew we were gonna do it so I
learned that her mom can live very well
her mom helped me a lot I really went
into character for me a lot and so she
thought we're gonna have dinner with her
mom and dad her mom and dad got into
traffic it was late one of the coolest
parts that happened by accident was our
room the balcony overlooked this deck
mm-hmm
so she was watching she was getting
ready and she was watching all these
flowers get brought in and he's tiki
torches get brought in all the stuff
she's like Michael someone must be
getting married up there tonight she
watched the whole thing get built nice
and had no idea that it was for her so I
I told her I said well was why we get a
drink wait for your parents and
everything that all my buddies told me
what happened happened like as your
leading closer I'm watching her get
ready
my dad's texting me I'm like getting
emotional so I'm having to I go to the
bathroom cuz we're in Tulum Mexico
there's no reason for me to be crying
right now so I'm watching all this and
it's just really I mean it's like gonna
happen like we have it yeah it's
happening we're in the moment and so
anyway we go downstairs I had these
flowers the rose petals from our door
yeah on the third floor back in the
corner all the way down the stairs yeah
she walks out she goes man the wind must
have really blown these flowers and I'm
going be kidding me we walk down the
stairs and the restaurant was to the
right the deck was to the left and I say
hey you said you want to check out the
deck let's check out the deck so we
walked through and there's like the
sandy area where she sees the flowers
again and as I'm watching her I'm
starting to see what she's going what's
happening here you know we go up the
stairs and there's flowers and tiki
torches and we go up there photographers
up there and so she start out putting
stuff together and I said well you said
you wanted photos in Mexico so I hired a
photographer yeah if we had a
photographer we probably have a mariachi
band and mic man Ezekiel who worked at
the place yeah we were like on it was
this was a smoothest thing I've ever
done well yeah I was like we need a
mariachi band point anyway we had a hand
signals like when I point
I need that mariachi band walking up I
pointed you hear the trumpets they come
walking up and I was like I have very
little bit of time to yeah to make this
happen so and
I brought it to spot and proposed so
it's important to have that wingman
Thank You Ann I think it was my guy yeah
yeah it really is like a scene in the
movie but like several movies like it
the planning part it's like a heist
movie it sounds like the like an oceans
movie the type of planning you guys had
to do and you know all the
cloak-and-dagger with her mom yeah it
was like I was on the phone your mom all
the time and her if she was she was
doing all the communication between us
and and the resort and just a lot of
moving parts for the biggest moment to
show your life yes so we're like I hope
this it looks like it's gonna be great
you know nothing's gonna be perfect and
I just wanted to be everything that she
deserved and yeah and and wanted it to
be a big moment for for both of us and
you know I said she's you know her mom
and dad's the only daughter but you know
boy child so I wanted it to be just a
big moment for all of us together and it
turned out to be even bigger and better
than I and as we really planned
were you nervous it was it like with
there are moments in there we were just
like oh man I don't know if this is
gonna go well you must have butterflies
at least oh yeah oh yeah one of my
favorite parts is with my friends we're
at like dude you're gonna act weird like
you're gonna be weird I'm like no I'm
not like we're gonna be cool I had to
bring on me like I would it was like the
heist like I had this ring yeah in this
bag that I got after Old Dominion gave
me this like gym bag after touring with
him yeah so I have this gym bag all I
have there is a pair of shoes and her
engagement ring but I had to keep it
with me at all times so I have this bag
with just his ring in it and my man
we're gonna be cool I had the ring for a
couple weeks but yeah left so I had this
bag with me everywhere thank God she
never questioned it was like why do you
cans bag man
but as it gets closer my buddies I'm
telling you dude you might not realize
it but you're gonna be weird she's gonna
think something's wrong and I'm like no
way promise you the night before we get
into our room I'm sitting there she's
like hey everything okay like it just
seemed like something's wrong I'm going
give me 15 hours this is always make a
lot of sense in about 15 18 hours yeah
but during the day I had this like it
was a beautiful day everything was going
so smooth and the resort was so great at
helping me get everything going yeah now
today tonight really have nerves during
the dams more
it's the day I was like excited yeah
right then I start seeing her get ready
then I started seeing the flowers come
up how did you start seeing all that and
it gets very real mm-hmm real fast and
my dad was texting me like I said and I
started getting that like just anxious
nervous it's like I need to do this yeah
I'm ready to do it and then I think when
I when I got down on a knee I told her I
said you guys did this apart this is our
first trip and want to be something
we'll never forget so I just got one
more question I went to get the ring out
got on me and she just shouted of course
I'll marry here I go I haven't asked you
yet it's so answer then but then we both
kind of blacked out it's a little gray
so thank God we have the photographer to
to capture that moment could to prove
that it proved that happened you had to
prove that we're actually Mary Kay we're
getting getting married because I yeah
we both were like oh it happened oh man
it was awesome it could have been
anybody
you